the biggest online retailer Amazon made
a huge announcement you probably heard
about this they're almost ready to go
with their upcoming drone delivery
system this is really going to happen
that's right a remote-controlled drone
is going to deliver this is real an
order to your home within minutes yes
Amazon's drone service is not publicly
available yet but I was asked to be one
of the first people to try it out and I
think you should do it you don't mind
I'm gonna order something right now just
do this and then I'm going to confirm
purchase and then press enter yeah okay
alright I was easy
alright let's see how fast the drone can
it's headed here now already my order is
on its way that's crazy yeah there's an
app where we can actually track it
through the skies we can see look at it
it's headed over the lush California
countryside is bring my Amazon package
it's headed here to the studio it's
coming into the studio it's hovering
over us right now it's here this is
fantastic
[Applause]
it's amazing ladies and John and I
cannot believe it my chandelier got here
in 47 seconds yeah but it's completely
smashed Oh Andy it's fine you're missing
the point
it came super super fast they're
cleaning it up I also ordered
[Applause]
I also ordered kettlebell weights
well he's dead but I think least they
can work the kinks out I think this is
going to work out just
[Applause]
they stole the pieces of my broken
chandelier hey thanks for watching be
sure to click subscribe to see even more
great Conan clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography